i first met our next speaker and his
lovely wife penny way back
in the last decade of the last century
if that sounds like a long time ago it
is
it was at the time i was studying for my
phd in political science
at the claremont graduate school and he
was the president of the claremont
institute
and what i quickly learned about him is
something hillsdale students today learn
about him and that's
the fact that he's a teacher he's always
teaching
he didn't teach formal classes back then
but he always took
the time to talk to us uh graduate
students
and by the way last night i mentioned
his love of tennis
his tea his love of teaching extended to
the tennis court
we used to play with some regularity
back in those
long ago days he was well skilled in the
fundamentals of the game and he loved to
teach those fundamentals
now what that meant in practice is that
not only would he uh trounce you on the
court
he would afterwards he would explain
exactly how he trounced you
well i would encourage you to come and
see us on the hillsdale campus
and what you'll see is he hasn't changed
a bit he's still
he still loves to teach and now he's
doing it in the classroom
he offers courses on a variety of
subjects including aristotle the
constitution
c.s lewis and totalitarian novels
it's been my privilege to work with him
at my alma mater for the past
now more than 20 years please welcome
back to the podium the 12th president
of hillsdale college larry p yarn
well i thought mark stein was going to
end up being given the best speech at
this thing but now there's doubt
uh thank you all for being here i'm
going to
excuse myself after lunch because i'm
having lunch with the governor
and
[Music]
[Applause]
and that's happening because i'm a
really important guy
it's uh uh that's happening because
he's one he's wanting to save the
country and he wants
charter schools and we know a lot about
that and
and i've had a new thought in the last
month that i'll tell you about
for some reason we have education
centers popping up all over the place
and we didn't really plan them well we
did the one in washington dc on capitol
hill we got a graduate school there and
a lot going on there
but there's one in summers connecticut
now
that's on the massachusetts border have
you heard about that
it was given to us by the founder and
builder of friendly ice cream
and it's a beautiful property and it has
an exact
replica of monticello on it and i
thought
okay he called up and said i'm going to
give you this property and i want to
give you 25 million dollars in endowment
to take care of it
and
i looked around for a minute couldn't
think of a reason to say no
now there's something like that in
california maybe two things
and then the other day i was reading
about our governor in michigan
and uh and i thought you know
california connecticut michigan
we need to go to a red state
so we may i'm going to talk to the
governor about
and see it'll be a great conversation
for him because
i'm confident other governors have done
this when i bring it up
well we'll help you christy christie
gnome
asked offered to build us an entire
campus in south dakota
and and i said
[Applause]
governor we don't take any money from
you we can't we can't do that
she said well maybe i could raise it i
said maybe i said but that would be
you know a lot so i don't want anything
from the governor
except to talk to him about it and
ask him to anticipate what's going to
happen
and i'll tell you what we're going to do
in these education cities
centers we now have
accumulated registered online students
above three and a half million
we have 26 charter schools and eight
more
opening in the next 18 months
[Applause]
uh we've got curricula and we've got
schools that we
advise in the running of and we have
hundreds of teachers come to our campus
in the
in the summer and we're getting to know
a lot about that
and so we're going to open a homeschool
division
and
we're going to do online courses for
credit uh
you know means you'll actually have to
study
and uh and uh first dual enrollment
courses
uh we're gonna start a master's degree
program in classical education pretty
soon i think
so that we can staff these schools
because the
great bottleneck is headmasters and
after that
teachers and you know a teaching
teaching is a
very high calling and they're not
trained that way anymore and that's too
bad
uh so these education centers will be
where those people can come
somewhere local and do in person
like this sort of and uh so
it's a grand adventure and uh
that's why i won't be here at lunch
today
um
now this crisis that we're in that's a
good segue into that
right because this is the most serious
kind of thing in my opinion
how do we understand it what is it and
then
what do we do about it and i'll mention
some examples from the past that give
hope
think of the resources that are gathered
by the ruling class
because that's what they are now um
the institutions in which we learn
starting with the most elite ones where
the fancy pants people are trained
um they are
in almost entirely woke now
uh williams college i have a friend
there teaches in political science and
he wrote an article in arrow magazine
what the woke movement at williams
college you can look it up
arrow is a e r o three online
it's a terrifying thing basically
school has stopped happening because
everybody's afraid to say anything
but that's just at the top because
the you know the staple university
in america today is of two kinds i mean
the modal
type the one that's most common it's
either a
second or third tier state university
where almost everybody goes to college
now
or else it's a broke liberal arts
college
and you know there i think there forbes
says there are 963 of those
and that maybe 30 percent of them are in
some kind of imminent trouble
and what happens at those state
universities is that they're
clones of the most elite to the best of
their ability
and very common that is it's the third
tier ones
and second tier one some the train the
teachers
and uh and they are teaching them
all the righteous stuff and they're
heavily under the influence of the state
education bureaucracy in every state
which is by the way more than half the
budget in every
state
and i'll mention about that that in the
public schools in america
this is a shocking fact and nobody talks
about it
did you know that more than half the
employees in public education today are
not teachers
do you know what the number is in a
charter school
it's about six teachers for every
non-teaching employee so first of all
more than half the budget never gets
anywhere near the school
and what do those people do well they're
they design what's to be taught
you know like that needs to be done by
the way i mean
if the one in this room who knows the
least about it
set out honestly to construct a basic
curriculum along the long established
lines
you would do it more or less
successfully in about a month
it's not that hard right human beings
grow up at about the same rate they
always did they need to know the same
things
they need to be good at the human skills
reading writing and arithmetic
they need natural history the natural
science
and the story of human beings in
literature and philosophy and history
and then you've done it right that's
everything
but no constantly inventing new ways to
teach them to read for example
whereas in our charter schools in our
hillsdale academy
we've never graduated to kindergarten or
who couldn't read
and the reason is they can already read
i mean in principle because you know my
granddaughter that makes me pity you um
she's already teaching herself to talk
right and she's you know she's going to
be like her mother she's never going to
shut up
but then once you talk because what
happens when you talk you know you say
uh glasses
there are many pairs of glasses right
and we don't look at
cue cards or flash cards to learn what
that is or to see a whole variety of
them right
we just look at it and we can see the
essence of it right
and then and then that word glasses
that's the equivalent of the mark it's
on a page
g-l-a-s-s-e-s right
and so all you got to do the reason it
works is because they've already taught
themselves
the sounds that's why phonics works
right
just apply phonics to the marks on the
page
and the point is a lot of them just
discover that for themselves
by the way but even if they don't
just teach them what the sounds are they
go with these letters
and you know what else i can't do it but
i was
i actually did do phonics in elementary
school and that was in
the late 17th century
so the point is
there's a huge load in this
and by the way their opinions tend to be
opinions that would justify their
existence
you see like a history teacher or a
science teacher or a lit teacher
they'll be doing that because they think
that those subjects are important and
they love them
whereas if you're a regulator of
education you're bound to think
education needs a lot of regulating
and what's wrong by the way with that
idea i said it this morning to the first
timers
if you become a teacher i mean it's just
a you know i didn't do it until i was 47
my father was a high school teacher in
arkansas uh and i just you know he was a
wonderful man and he found his happiness
doing that
never made any money but i started doing
it when i decided to go into the college
business and i
my first job in the colleges in a
college is the one i've got today
and i started teaching and a great
truth that i knew only in principle was
born in upon me
and that is you don't teach them
they learn you just help them
and if you explain to them the most
beautiful thing you know
something that might have taken you
years of devotion and love
to learn if you don't do it the right
way you'll just bore the heck out of
them
and the way not to do that is to ask
them before you tell them
it's good to tell them why this might be
important
but what is that thing that's socrates
question that's he's always asking tst
what is
what is this what is that right
well education is control of a vast
engine that obscures that fact
and therefore dehumanizes the kids in
a more general and less intense way than
making them transgender when they're too
young to decide
now large parts of the way we gather and
report information
is in concentrated hands
an element i think of this ruling class
i think that what college professors
have done
because you know being a college
professor is
uh
it ain't sexy by today's terms right
they they uh i can tell you what they're
i've been i've interviewed more than 450
people for faculty jobs in 21 years
i just love it i just i i've just
learned to respect them so deeply
and here's the thing they're all used to
being among the smartest people they
ever met
they are you know and uh you know
and and they could go to law school or
med school
and there'd be a guaranteed path to a
big income
and they don't they get three times as
much education and they're going to make
a third as much
now why did they make that choice the
good ones and
the ones at hillsdale are good there's a
love
they love they want to know
and and they too see
they carry their excellence inside
themselves
there's a fire that burns in them to get
them all that way
and then they want to teach well
the trouble is you'll never get rich and
you don't really get to tell anybody
adult what to do so what if
this is a great engineering project that
was born in the progressive era in
american universities came from germany
we could be the ones who would plan the
future of society
now we will rule you see we'll be
important we'll be
powerful i once stayed in suburbs
outside
washington dc and went in on the metro
uh and i just looked who was there
and uh i recognized a couple of people
and i asked a couple of others who they
were and they were academics
going in to decide what the government
was going to do today
and that's you know kind of intoxicating
and
strong men of affair men and women of
affairs right
so
they they dominate journalism now and
see journalists are just like college
professors because
what they used to be was servants
of the truth that speech that we just
heard
it was uh i just invited abigail to come
teach because
it was disciplined and what was it
discipline to
the facts as she has seen them
and in the course of it she named a
whole bunch of things that were curious
to me
but sounded very plausible like for
example
there are a lot of people who have
gender dysphoria and i've never doubted
that
and i've never know they shouldn't have
help but
it's possible that this could even be
help to some people
and you shouldn't begrudge that right
and that means that
she followed what she saw and that means
she's not master of the universe
she's just beholding it right and this
new temper
is better it's all a contest for power
and journalists today
they go look at things and they report
them that's what they're supposed to do
right and they have struggled to do it
objectively and they got to take
care it's just like the scholars art
except it's stuff that's
moving every day right well what if
instead they get to decide who's the
next president of the united states
that's a cool station if you read and
washington post really writes these the
most if you read the stories about who
gets to go to the white house press
conference
you can tell the high journalists think
they own that space
right that's our space you see and
they're the media
they're between us and something and we
can't have direct access to that
something
that's that's the phenomenon right and
uh i liked it that trump would pick
nobody's to come in there it really
ticked them off see
but that that space right
that's the space that belongs to the
american people
and it's reserved for the person they
elect to be the chief executive
but no these guys on that space now
it's like a bigger deal power
the major corporations do you know those
this stuff that went on in the last few
months and it's going on all the time
you know threatening this state for
example right now
about a transgender law well
a few two years ago i think it was bezos
and
tim cook and the whole gang you know who
they they actually have more money than
everybody else
if you include their money in that
and they decided that they would
renounce what was called the friedman
rule from milton friedman
and the friedman rule was the assets of
a public corporation belong to the
shareholders
and they should be used for the purpose
of advancing and
shareholder value and if they want to
give to charity give their own money
and give the give the charity money back
to the to the shareholders and they
they just specifically renounced that
and that means what they were saying in
the plainest language was
we're going to take other people's money
now and we're going to decide how to
affect the society
power you see power
i think steve jobs is probably a great
man
and i think the ones who follow him are
not so great but one of the reasons was
he always thought he was conforming to
the demands
of beauty and utility in making his
products
and he was very disciplined about that
right
well that means that all acts of
creativity
of high worth are also great acts of
obedience
it's obedience we don't like anymore we
like to tell people what to do you know
that obedience
was one of winston churchill's favorite
words
he he was he always thought he was
obeying
that's why he was so stubborn
then there's the regulatory state
and that's 24 million people
most of them at the state level but it's
very much a system that ins that
influences from the top
down and they're a class a person
and they're not what they used to be you
churchill said that famous thing once
no longer civil and no longer servants
well there there's that going on you
know
in the early progressive era r.j
pastrito publishes
about about that he's the dean of our
graduate school in a politics department
they thought that separation of powers
was no longer needed
because now there's going to be a class
of person working in the government
who will have a guaranteed salary that
cannot be reduced
it'll be enough to support them and
they'll have tenure in office
forever and that means they won't have
any needs
or interest and so they won't pursue
their needs and interest
in politics if you look at a list of the
10 biggest givers in politics today
and partisan elections all on one side
the public
union employee unions are tops
because they're people too and they have
interest
and they like a world in which people
like them
decide things and in the name not of
consent
the popular thing in the name of science
you see i mean the pandemic is the
craziest thing in the world to me
because when you know we decided we were
going to have college
you know up to the point of threat of
arrest
which i've had and uh and
so but you know i didn't want to do that
recklessly as i tell the students
if you get sick and die although we can
get more
it would be very it'll be very
inconvenient to me
and so so
i say that all the time you know it's a
weird thing that he'll call it the
mothers like that
[Music]
they're like spartan women you know
anyway
i didn't want them to die disrupt the
schedule and
uh and so i tried to find out and we
found ourselves
in association with some people that i
think are just geniuses
jay bhattacharya scott atlas daniel
halperin
um
[Applause]
and so and and you know then after that
it's easy
right because i have to obey the law
if they actually make a law although
what they make now is
memos from the governor and that's not
really how a law gets made you know
uh and those can be challenged in court
and we are ready to do it
but you know
i'll tell you this my we have these
doctors from the mayo clinic
and the mayo clinic is very cautious
about the
coronavirus and they're worried about
the long-term effects and all that
and uh and you know they don't you know
they always say are you worried about
the long-term effects and i said
no i'm busy i got a lot to do
i said but anyway we can't know that
right
i mean it's exactly like the point made
earlier about reversibility of some of
these things but it hasn't been long
enough to know right
well anyway one of them was kind of
critical of me
well he's a friend but you know he said
you
really picked the experts that were for
opening up and i said sure
and he said oh he didn't you're
surprised i'd admit that
and i said look doc are you guys the
tops in the world at the mayo clinic
and he said well we're pretty good and i
said how about these guys at stanford
are they okay
expert knowledge this ruling class
operates in the name of expertise
and that's a different title to rule
than consent
the consent of equal souls
and this expertise has got to be
strictly limited
as winston churchill explained
expert knowledge is narrow knowledge
you know imagine one of those sets of
parents
and the kid comes under this gender
thing
what are you going to do that's a really
hard decision
right because you're going to stand up
to a lot of people and they're powerful
and they might take your kid
or you're going to leave the kid there
and try to cope with it
there's no good answer to that question
but nobody is better qualified to make
the judgment
than a mother
uh churchill there's a so one
i'm going to give you some instances
where things have been like this where
everything was at stake and we might
lose
our freedom uh and
one of them is in 1948 1945 to 1951
after the second world war the
socialists came in
big majority and they're not they're not
like these guys that we've got today
they had been announcing for 50 years
what they were going to do
and then they won a big majority and
churchill
always said that it would be the death
of civilization and freedom
but by golly they're entitled to do it
and so what we're going to do is
complain about it
and then reverse it later and
and he he uh
his campaign this is the key thing i'm
going to say today
from 1945 to 1952 winston churchill
led the conservative party on a campaign
against socialism under the title
socialism versus the people
you see and he would point out to them
that practical decisions
always involve a hundred factors then
and we by the way we make them every day
every one of us there's no more intense
or practical
or consequential decision then how to
raise your kid
well mr douglas j
of the home office in the atlee
socialist administration
said a famous thing and it echoes now if
you know anything about british history
your modern brother sister you'll know
this
he said mothers do not always understand
how to feed their children the gentleman
in whitehall that's the governing center
of britain
the gentleman in whitehall know better
and he made the terrible mistake of
saying that in the hearing of winston
churchill
and churchill rang the changes on that
but you see
what that means this i just i just named
a four-part vast apparatus
that is working together and that
controls directly and indirectly more
than half of the economy in the united
states
and europe right that is a
formidable force it's huge
and how are you going to stop it and
it's proceeding
under the under the principle that you
can't
teach a kid to read without
expertise you know which is stupid
because you know first of all a lot of
them learn to read on their own
and so that's the point
that's by the way why it will eventually
become ugly and be
despotic despite kind intentions
because this is the thing that has to
justify itself and
it's furiously at work on that all the
time
this happened in 1776
in 1860 in 1945 in britain
and in 1979 in britain
things were as bad as this in all those
occasions
now i'm not going to talk a lot about
russia in 1917
because that's a counter-example in
other words
the russian revolution succeeded and it
succeeded by
heartbreakingly narrow margins
and the lives of 100 million people were
at stake and they lost their lives
because of that well world communism
russia was not as good at killing as
china
it was maybe 35 million in russia
and you know so that's a sad one right
but those won the american revolution
the civil war
the rise of margaret thatcher in britain
and the post-war churchill only time he
was he became prime minister
in 1951 and his combat against socialism
which by the way that 1951 to 55
administration got rid of part of
socialism
and margaret thatcher got rid of the
less the rest
and i'll tell you what those things have
in common
first of all a movement started
notice how many people are in this room
right
people last night people would say but
the american people
accept this now why is there no movement
against it
and to both of them i said look around
you know
i mean i'm telling you we we at the
college
whatever line of operation we're in
admissions faculty hiring
events charter schools online students
we can't beat them off with a stick and
that's you know it makes a person
optimistic when he sees that
especially when he sees you know because
we have we have this big national mess
that we've
made but it all radiates from a tight
little world
that we're all in and we get to measure
the effects of what we do and say
before our eyes every day it's just so
fine and such a grand thing to be able
to do
and uh and it helps a lot it makes us
better
we think so this
is a movement and you know the
the the next part is uh greatness
uh some great
leader and that's extremely
unpredictable it's in uh
in the classic works uh statesmanship
which is a form of art
a very difficult form of human making or
art
is understood as a synonym for chance
in churchill's writing very often
because you know chances
is the intersection of two causes that
produce a third result that neither of
them
would have produced on its own uh
and two independent causes right so
if you you know if snow gets on the
branch
the branch breaks off that's nature
saw off the branch that's art
saw off the branch on the top of the
head of somebody standing below
that's either chance or a misdemeanor
and
and uh and that and so
why would you think that these extremely
rare and artful people
would also be chants well the reason is
can't control when they show up and
sometimes you really need them
now would be good but
they didn't make the movements
those started because people saw
something
and it disturbed them nobody was worried
about great britain before
1763 in america but then the they won
they won the big war with france and
they've got this whacking big empire and
it just comes to them maybe we ought to
use it
and then just so happens over there they
had a terrible failure of statesmanship
because the great men in britain at that
time
edmund burke and william pitt were
friends of the american revolution
no they were governed by lord north who
was an idiot
and and that made but you know they
started doing
things to people who'd been governing
themselves for 150 years
right and they didn't like it and then
there was a kind of a igniter
tom paine wrote common sense before that
george whitefield who's the greatest
preacher probably he was the billy
billy graham of the 18th century uh
and he would get 30 000 people to come
and hear him preach
and he was preaching about faith but
also freedom
and he became big friends with ben
franklin
who was not particularly orthodox in his
christian views
and they became friends because ben
franklin went he said
no way he can talk to 30 000 people
and so he went and stood by the stage
and he
walked away and counted his paces
until he could just barely hear him but
could hear him
and then he measured you know ben
franklin was kind of a lunatic
i mean a very great man but you know he
was very
meticulous he uh measured the space
and how many people could stand in the
space thirty thousand
now those things were sort of catalyst
or igniters
but then somebody came along to guide
all of that and you know
don't think that the situation is more
difficult now than it was in 1776
a people who had never had an army never
had a government
of their own were about to make war on
the greatest power on earth
in 1860 people say
to me sometimes uh
we could never have a great revival like
we had in 1860
1858 to 1860 because people
don't pay attention to politics
thirty thousand people came to listen to
the lincoln douglas debates
and i urge you to read them they're
they're sublime
douglas is very artful and very powerful
lincoln is sublime and he destroyed
douglas and yeah thirty thousand people
they went on three and a half four hours
each one there ate them and then they
came on their horses and they sat in the
sun
and they say you know people haven't
done that since well i said you know
they never did that before either but
something important was going on
right this slavery thing was extremely
troubling
and from every point of view they the
the wicked ones who thought that they
deserved to own
the slaves they were afraid they were
going to lose it but really what they
were afraid of is they couldn't expand
it
and others for a mixture of reasons
the the sublime of which is equality and
freedom
but also mixed around that we don't
really want a lot of black people in
this state
and that's the cauldron that abraham
lincoln stood up and he was a shabby
lawyer everybody thought he was a hobo
when they first saw him
and uh fred stephen douglas
dressed in ruffled shirts and had
matched horses on his carriage
he just like looked like the aristocracy
coming to town
and and see people
listen to those arguments
that's happening more and more
uh in in uh 1948
churchill raids that campaign and you
know he was a one-man
wrecking ball in the house of commons he
could just do
amazing things he he by himself
built the movement that got britain to
re-arm just barely enough to survive
1940.
and at first he had five or six
backbenchers who were in disrepute and
they were the only ones who'd listened
to him
but he was very good at what he did and
the people
you see he he uh
people kept writing him he started a
group called the focus
and the purpose of it was
we're not going to fight with each other
about anything else
we're going to unite i mean we can be
socialist and we can be capitalist we
can be whatever
we're going to agree that we have to
stop adolf hitler from conquering great
britain
that's all well there are hundreds of
thousands of people
in that thing and it just grew from
nowhere i got no help from the bbc
because just remember what i said about
learning to read
and about teaching the salvation
of the united states of america is in
each citizen
and we're going to find out if they're
still americans
and if they're not it's already over but
i think they are and they
are going to produce the conditions for
a turnaround
or else those conditions won't be
produced
margaret thatcher i i happen to be
living there at the time
i i i went over there to get my girl
and uh by the way i was very relieved
that it's rare for women in their 50s
and 60s to go transgender
i've been
i told penny that and she said we should
ask her about men
[Laughter]
uh i i was working on the official
biography of winston churchill
and you know that was great but then
margaret thatcher became the leader of
the conservative party and then prime
minister in 1979
right in the middle of the time that i
was living there with my
soon to be mrs and it was just
the most thrilling thing you ever saw it
was like you know i like
tennis and so there and we'd watch
wimbledon on tv that was the mcenroe
versus board gears
and this was better
margaret thatcher arguing with james
callahan the
socialist prime minister and she was the
the way the
the the adjectives they used for her was
shrill
she's shrill right well she's a woman
you know she didn't sound like a man
but lord what she wasn't was shrill she
was tough
and uh and then she broke him down
every year every and you know he by the
way was the last great
taunter of winston churchill early in
callahan's career and laid in
churchill's career
and so he's pretty formidable right
and she took him down and broke him and
then what was their situation
it's as bad as this first of all the
labor party had a majority
and they were ruled by the trade union's
council a majority of whom
were open members of the communist party
and then these these labor unions were
extremely strong
and they would shut down parts of the of
the country if you
they'd make a demand very often on the
government because there were still some
socialized
the railroads and the phone company and
some of those
and and they just demand what they
wanted
and then in the winter they'd stop
communication couldn't get milk and
they would uh pick it not only a company
they were in dispute with it was
picketing private people
the government everybody but they'd pick
their
you pick it their customers and
suppliers too called secondary picketing
and uh edward heath who was a weenie
i was elected prime minister before
margaret thatcher
he had promised to stop this if he got a
majority he got a majority and he didn't
stop it
and he gave in to the unions in the
middle of the winter
people were getting cold so she says she
won't do that
right and she gets elected and i can
remember the day i was watching the news
because you know they had shut down a
part of yorkshire up in the north
uh you know part of the city of york
a region an area of it where there was
an industry a lot of different companies
working together and they just closed
the whole thing down and the city wasn't
working
and the bbc is there reporting and then
then the reporter heard something he
looked
and he said oh there's a convoy coming
and it was buses and trucks and what was
in the buses was london cops
and what was in the trucks was portable
fencing
and they elected about they arrested
about 5 000 people
and they put them in these fences they
built
and then that was over and then the next
day the uh
the bbc was showing guys in dark suits
and briefcases
going to union offices to seize their
assets
and you know by five o'clock the next
day there were negotiations going on
about this and that you know she was
just
she she is the the firmest
example of executive action i've seen
with my own eyes
not more form i you know i was
privileged to know her pretty well
and i was privileged to know ronald
reagan and i always say to him mr
president
because i was sometimes critical of him
to him
and i i said mr president the greatest
man i ever met
and he would remember and say yeah but
you think margaret's greater
and i'd say
what's to happen today well
it it both options just like in all of
these crises i've named
remember there was a movement
and there was somebody to guide and lead
it
and it became clear and it was fought
through
sometimes with violence sometimes not
well once you see that that's a kind of
pattern that's what's happened in the
past
first of all you understand this is very
formidable
because for most of the american
revolution and most of the civil war
most of the second world war different
kind of crisis but by the way similar
forces
uh the people who eventually won
couldn't imagine that they could win
they thought they were fighting to the
death you see
and that means that we may have to
undergo that
but we should take comfort from things
like this because
this is my final point
freedom is a beautiful thing
the constitution united states is a
beautiful thing
the declaration of independence is the
most beautiful political document
ever written and then the first line
of aristotle's ethics he says that every
choice we make and every action we take
and every inquiry we we take all
seem to aim at some good and the highest
form of the good is the beautiful
we all long for that these things that
they're doing now
they're dangerous because they parade in
the name of the beautiful
but if they're not beautiful that can't
last
and that means just like in every kid
there's the potential to breathe
in every human breast there's the
potential to fight for freedom
the thing to do now is to communicate
to everyone you know
learn get better teach
don't make yourself a nuisance well
later that might be right
you know you can't one of the iron rules
in
excellent education is you can't teach
people who don't want to learn
because it's hard for them you know and
that means don't annoy people
make it easy if you see something lovely
and you want people to read
send it to some people and say you
probably don't have to read this but i
found it good
right and then you're not challenging
them you know i i get
i get a lot of recommendations like that
and sometimes with the challenge
sometimes people write
well if you're really serious about your
job then you know
and now you see right back i'm not
see just like it's true
you know the thing about a despotic
movement
they always know who their numbers are
because everybody's sort of bought and
paid for
whereas a free movement
it's of infinite size as many as there
are people
when abraham lincoln called for 75 000
troops
in what in march of 1861
he didn't know if they'd come he did
know that there was a hostile
army that almost had the capital
surrounding surrounded
and if maryland seceded and it was about
to then washington dc would be encircled
he knew that and he didn't know if there
could be
any help well that's where we are too
remember because we're on the free side
and that means people who are free will
join us
or else they will not let's get them too
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
now i want to tell those of you in the
front that many of those people in the
back were standing up and you were not
if you didn't like my speech get out
thank you dr arn we now have time for a
few questions
if you would like to ask a question
please come find your way to a
microphone
okay
question to the speakers left dr aaron
thank you so much thanks for the
invitation
um we are first timers we're so glad to
be here
and i'm so glad you mentioned mrs
thatcher and president reagan
last week i started to use one of his
quotes
as my new signature block the future
doesn't belong to the faint-hearted
it belongs to the brave that's it
yeah see
what i you know the two great talks
we've talked
i heard so far had many things in common
and one of the best was
speak your peace right this
not wanting to be rude you shouldn't be
rude
but you shouldn't be afraid of being
called rude
and that means if somebody's doing
something that you think is disastrous
there's only two cures and one of them
is to argue with them and the other is
to shoot them
and and arguing with them is a lot
better
[Applause]
question to the speakers right
sir you're uh
you've got a lot to say there but
there's one concern i have
right now if you speak up your stand
alone
uh and that's a very dangerous place to
be
because our government can just grab you
up so what do we do
well first of all i envy that beard
i bet you get a lot of girls
[Laughter]
just one you got one yeah that's that's
what i got
um it's not the same one i don't think
though
so the the thing is yeah in the
beginning
but you know last summer
i mean i'm afraid it's going to be as
bad this summer
last summer all these events started
unfolding and i think that they're
connected
i think that the pandemic policies which
i think are
absurd and have cost many lives
whereas if we'd identified and focused
on the people that's what the great
barrington
exploration calls for right and it just
seems so sensible to me
especially if you take into account the
fact that people shouldn't have to shut
their businesses
and you know stay home and you have the
right to assemble what about that anyway
and then that led to you know then the
race riots
and then the election and you know
those are violent things and terrible
things and the pressures were enormous
and so doug jeffrey whose external
affairs at the college and
my longest serving colleague pity him
what do we do on in primus except the
pandemic
and the race riots and the election
and nobody else was doing that and
you know so i thought okay we're going
to be destroyed
we did it anyway and and that you know
but
million you know i i i i could give you
a list
of the code so in we got to you know
everybody got petitions up social media
movements that you have to make a
statement
and we you know so we had a bunch of
them do that
and we don't answer statements if
somebody gives me a petition
before i open it i say well i'll read
this if you want me to but i promise
whatever
you're asking me to do i'm going to do
the opposite
do you want me to read it anyway and we
don't answer them right
well i got ticked off about the one
about black lives matter
the thing that got me was they said that
we're coasting
on the experience of
the founders of the college and we've
got to stop
talking about them now so
we answered that and you know we
david whalen most of it he's a very
talented man he wrote most of that
and it was awesome and they printed it
in the wall street journal
and then i had college presidents from
all over the country write me and praise
that
and every time i thought and where were
you
so the point is somebody has to start
[Applause]
[Applause]
i'm a hillsdale grandparent so uh this
is my first time to be
here but i was a classroom teacher
for 41 years a teacher
not an educator i really get tired of
everybody being described as educators
i feel like i was a teacher that's all i
ever wanted to do was teach chemistry
i loved my students
you just you just said a lot of
information about yourself
well i want to know what's your opinion
about
educators versus teachers since you
describe yourself as a teacher
we're all teachers my dad was a teacher
yeah you know and by the way you know
what the verb that they use for teaching
in the bureaucratic in in the core
curriculum
in the co in all curriculum talk
uh teaching is called delivery
you see and that's the point is teachers
are now like conveyor belts
uh there's somebody prepares a package
you don't really even have to know
what's in it just take it down there and
give it to that guy
that's that's the model and it's
devastating and it's demeaning do you
ever watch uh
so in in the great western movies
there's often a school teacher
and the cowboys take their hats off when
they go on the school
and they're polite around the teacher
and the teacher
is a symbol of wisdom in the society and
often functions
in the film to survive supply knowledge
right like we always had girls at
hillsdale college
and you know you had to know greek and
latin
to get into the college back then our
standards have slipped
and uh and they had a prep school to
teach those things what happened to
those women
they all became teachers of their
families and everybody in their region
and they functioned as the wisest people
and most knowledgeable people on the
scene right
well now they're delivery boys and girls
and that's just
devastating demotion and you know
some of them we notice
uh if you want to get a job at hillsdale
college do not ever manifest this point
some of them take pride that they wrote
curricula that other people had to
follow
and you know we write curricula for that
you know
15 or 20 000 students are studying all
the time
but we write it with the teachers so
yeah
good point question to the speakers
right
hi dr arn i'm a homeschool mom
of seven and my first three are at
hillsdale
[Applause]
and
what is your name wendy moody
oh moody yeah i'm sorry i threw those
three out
i understand why i did too
but homeschooling is a counter-cultural
thing to do
and very difficult so my question is
what would you say to encourage
the homeschool movement oh man now is
dan peters here
the trustee you're in the room dan
good i was going to praise him um
he uh so i just learned something
exciting first of all we're going to do
curriculum and video and helps for
homeschoolers
we're starting to work on that now and
and you know i'm uh ignorant and
so i never i never heard of this but in
hillsdale michigan there's a co-op
and that's a bunch of home school moms
they're mostly faculty moms by the way
they
teach part-time at the college some of
them and they get together and they
form a little school with the kids in
their families
and now i've just learned that i have
another employee i'm going to hire her
husband too
i decided the other day and they're in a
group of 50
in jackson up the road so
don't you see i i think here's my
exciting
excited idea that's
in fact what all schools used to be
right and you know
you don't
people with the will who are reasonably
intelligent
can build and run a great school
if they get help it's better we help
them
but that there's no reason
that in k through 12
let's say k through nine
there's no real reason why you need
an administration in a school
and so yeah and
and you know in hillsdale we find that
the
homeschoolers uh you know first of all
you know it's hard to get into hillsdale
and uh
uh so it's the success rates are very
high
back when there was more failure than
there is now
the homeschoolers stood out because they
never failed
and why i think you know one of the
challenges when you get to
college is there's a lot more work and
it's harder
and you've got to concentrate for longer
and you know homeschoolers are mostly
taught by mom and she's busy
they have to learn on their own a lot
and i think that's good for them
yeah so i encourage that very much
[Applause]
please join me in thanking dr arne
[Applause]